En France, on a la chance de vivre en démocratie
et on est évidemment une très grande majorité à penser
qu'il s'agit du meilleur des systèmes politiques.
Une des choses qu'implique la démocratie c'est que le peuple
a le pouvoir de choisir ceux qui le gouvernent.
Très bien.
Mais la manière qu'on a de les choisir,
c'est-à-dire notre système de vote,
est-ce qu'on est sûr qu'il est le meilleur ?
Eh bien... non, pas vraiment, il est même assez mauvais
et en fait, on pourrait faire beaucoup mieux.
[Générique]
En France, sous la Vème république, l'élection reine,
c'est évidemment l'élection présidentielle
et elle se déroule dans ce qu'on appelle
un scrutin uninominal à deux tours.
Uninominal, ça veut dire qu'on ne vote
que pour une seule personne.
Au premier tour, on a plein de candidats et on garde
les deux meilleurs pour les départager au deuxième tour.
Ça paraît simple comme système, au point qu'on ne voit pas
très bien comment on pourrait faire beaucoup mieux que ça.
Et pourtant, on sait que ce système de vote
produit des dysfonctionnements.
L'exemple typique, c'est évidemment
l'élection présidentielle de 2002.
Alors, petit rappel pour ceux qui ne s'en souviennent pas
ou qui n'étaient pas nés,
le 21 avril 2002, au premier tour, Jacques Chirac,
qui était le président sortant,
arrive en tête avec 19.9% des voix.
Et à la surprise générale, c'est Jean-Marie Le Pen
qui termine deuxième avec 16.9%,
juste devant Lionel Jospin à 16,2%.
Et on a donc un second tour Chirac - Le Pen,
et Chirac l'emporte largement.
Ce qu'il y a de bizarre dans le déroulement de cette élection,
c'est que Lionel Jospin se trouve éliminé de peu,
alors que les sondages de l'époque montraient
que s'il avait été au deuxième tour,
il aurait peut-être gagné,
aussi bien face à Le Pen que face à Chirac.
Alors à l'époque, on avait attribué l'élimination de Lionel Jospin
à la présence d'autres "petites" candidatures à gauche.
Il y avait notamment Jean-Pierre Chevènement, qui avait fait 5.3%
et Christiane Taubira qui avait fait 2,3%.
On avait déjà vu plus ou moins la même chose
dans l'élection précédente, celle de 1995.
Edouard Balladur, qui était archi-favori
quelques semaines avant le scrutin,
s'est fait sortir de peu du premier tour.
Et on pense que si Philippe De Villiers,
qui avait fait 4.7%, ne s'était pas présenté,
c'est peut-être Balladur qui aurait été
au deuxième tour à la place de Chirac.
Le problème dans ces élections, ce n'est évidemment pas
ce qu'on pense de Jospin, Le Pen ou Balladur, non.
C'est le fait qu'à chaque fois, on a un candidat
qui a une chance réelle de l'emporter,
et qui se trouve mis hors course à cause de la présence
d'un petit candidat, proche de son camp,
qui lui, n'a aucune chance d'aller au bout.
C'est quand même vraiment bizarre, comme situation!
Tenez, supposez qu'on ait ça en sport.
Imaginez qu'à la finale du 100 mètres aux Jeux
Olympiques, ça se joue entre 2 - 3 grands favoris
et que les petits candidats, ceux qui n'ont
aucune chance de remporter la médaille,
aient le droit de retenir les favoris par le short!
Et que finalement celui qui gagne la course
ne soit pas forcément celui qui court le plus vite
mais celui qui aura réussi à se faire le moins retenir par le short...
On trouverait ça complètement stupide!
Anti-sportif! Absurde! Injuste!
Et pourtant c'est exactement ce qu'il se passe
à l'élection présidentielle!
L'issue du scrutin est influencée de manière décisive
par la présence ou l'absence de certains petits candidats.
Et on trouve ça juste.
Alors qu'on parle d'un truc qui est quand même autrement
plus important que la finale du 100 mètres, hein!
C'est quand même "juste" l'avenir du pays...
Mais bon! On s'est habitués à vivre
avec cette bizarrerie démocratique
au point qu'on la trouverait presque normale.
Et pour la compenser, on a inventé un truc
qui s'appelle le "vote utile".
Le principe du vote utile, c'est de se forcer
à ne PAS voter pour le candidat qu'on préfère,
celui qu'on souhaiterait sincèrement voir élu,
mais à voter pour un candidat qu'on aime moins
mais qui est mieux placé.
En plus, à côté du vote utile, il y a l'inverse, c'est le vote protestataire,
qui consiste justement à voter pour quelqu'un que,
dans le fond, on ne souhaiterait pas franchement voir élu.
Bon, donc au final on est en démocratie, c'est super,
on peut choisir nos dirigeants, très bien.
Mais la méthode par laquelle on les choisit
est complètement buguée!
C'est quand même un peu dommage, non?
Est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas trouver une manière
différente d'élire le président ou la présidente
qui évite tous ces problèmes?
Un mode de scrutin qui soit plus efficace,
plus robuste, plus représentatif.
Eh bien figurez-vous que cette question, elle a été étudiée
par des politologues et des mathématiciens
et qu'on peut l'aborder sous l'angle de la science.
[Générique]
Ce qui ne va pas dans le système actuel, on l'a vu,
c'est que le score de candidats mineurs
qui n'ont aucune chance de l'emporter
peut décider de qui passe au second tour
et donc du vainqueur potentiel.
Alors petite parenthèse, cette situation
n'est pas spécifique à la France.
Aux Etats-Unis c'est même encore pire
puisqu'il n'y a qu'un tour de scrutin.
Alors leur tradition politique est faite pour que,
normalement, il n'y ait que deux candidats
mais dès que ce n'est pas le cas, c'est le bordel.
En 1992 George Bush, le père,
se représentait contre Bill Clinton
et normalement Bush aurait dû l'emporter.
Sauf qu'il y a eu un troisième candidat,
Ross Perot, un indépendant plutôt à droite,
qui avait fait presque 20% et donc
avait pris une partie des voix de Bush
et c'est Bill Clinton qui avait gagné.
Pour éviter ce genre de situation,
que ce soit en France ou aux Etats-Unis,
une solution serait peut-être de faire
plus de tours de scrutin.
Dans sa forme extrême on pourrait même imaginer
qu'on élimine un seul candidat à chaque tour
et on fait autant de tours que nécessaire
pour désigner un vainqueur.
Si on faisait comme ça, chacun serait libre
de voter pour un petit candidat
dans les premiers tours si c'est vraiment sa conviction,
sans que ce soit ça qui ait une influence
déterminante sur le scrutin.
Alors là, vous allez me dire que ce système est un peu compliqué.
A la dernière élection présidentielle il y avait dix candidats
donc on aurait dû faire neuf tours de scrutin
et on aurait mis plusieurs mois à élire le président.
Et bien non en fait on n'a pas besoin
de faire autant de tours de scrutin,
il existe une solution pour régler le problème en un seul tour.
L'idée c'est de demander aux électeurs,
non plus de mettre un seul bulletin dans l'urne
mais de classer tous les candidats par ordre de préférence.
Avec ça on peut déterminer le résultat de tous les tours
de scrutin les uns après les autres
alors voici comment on fait.
Pour simuler le premier tour, on regarde seulement
le premier choix de chaque électeur,
on calcule le pourcentage des votes
que chaque candidat a obtenu
et on regarde qui est arrivé dernier.
Ce dernier on l’élimine, c'est-à-dire qu'on le retire
du classement de chacun des électeurs.
Pour simuler le deuxième tour, on prend  à nouveau
le premier choix de chaque électeur,
sauf pour ceux qui avaient classé  premier
le candidat qui vient d’être éliminé.
Pour ceux-là on se reporte sur leur deuxième choix.
On calcule à nouveau les pourcentages
obtenus par chaque candidat
on trouve le dernier et on l’élimine.
On recommence comme ça jusqu'à ce qu'il n'y ait plus
que deux candidats et qu'on puisse désigner un vainqueur.
Cette méthode de scrutin existe  vraiment,
on l'appelle le vote alternatif
et elle est utilisée notamment pour élire
la chambre des représentants en Australie,
pour élire le président irlandais
et dans certaines municipalités américaines.
Alors la supériorité de cette méthode
par rapport à notre scrutin à deux tours,
c'est qu'elle nous permet de bien mieux exprimer nos opinions.
Le problème du scrutin uninominal,
c'est que quand on vote pour quelqu'un,
on ne dit absolument rien de ce qu'on  pense de tous les autres.
C'est-à-dire qu'on réduit toute la complexité
de nos opinions sur les candidats
au choix d'un seul nom,
alors qu'avec le vote alternatif on peut exprimer
de manière beaucoup plus riche nos préférences
puisqu'on classe tous les candidats.
Alors est-ce que c'est la méthode
de scrutin parfaite, ce vote alternatif ?
Et bien non, pas vraiment en fait.
Déjà pour l'électeur elle n'est pas super simple,
en général, on sait les candidats qu'on aime ou qu'on déteste
mais arriver à classer tous les candidats quand il y en a
10 ou 12, ce n'est pas toujours évident.
Et cette méthode de scrutin, elle permet de traiter les cas
ou il y a plein de petits candidats comme en France,
mais dès qu'on se retrouve arrivé à l'avant-dernier tour,
il n'y a plus que trois candidats
et on se retrouve dans la situation habituelle,
celle d'un scrutin à deux tours.
Et on va voir qu'avec trois candidats et deux tours,
il peut déjà se passer des choses absurdes.
[Générique]
Alors, imaginons qu'on n'ait plus que deux tours,
que ça soit du vote alternatif
ou bien un scrutin classique à 2 tours comme on le fait aujourd'hui.
Supposons qu'on ait trois candidats, François, Nicolas et Marine.
Oui, je fais exprès de prendre des personnes réelles
pour que vous puissiez mieux visualiser les choses.
Mais ce que je vais illustrer est tout à fait général,
c'est lié aux mathématiques du vote
et donc ce n'est pas dépendant de ces personnes-là
ou des camps qu'elles représentent.
Supposons que 34 % de l'électorat choisisse de classer
François devant Nicolas et Nicolas devant Marine,
que 32% des gens préfèrent Nicolas à François
et François à Marine
et que 34% des gens préfèrent Marine à Nicolas
et Nicolas à François.
C'est une situation simplifiée mais relativement crédible, non ?
Simulons le premier tour, chacun vote pour son candidat préféré,
François fait 34 %, Marine aussi et Nicolas
seulement 32% donc il est éliminé.
Simulons maintenant le deuxième  tour.
Ceux qui avaient voté pour Nicolas au premier tour
se reportent sur François
donc François fait 66% et marine 34%
et donc François est largement élu.
Ok, maintenant imaginons que les choses
ne se soient pas passées comme ça.
Imaginons que François ait fait une campagne plus efficace
et qu'il ait réussi à prendre 3 % de l'électorat à Marine.
On aura donc les pourcentages suivants
pour les différents classements,
François, Nicolas, Marine 37%,
Nicolas, François, Marine, toujours 32%
et Marine, Nicolas, François 31%.
On simule le premier tour, François fait 37 %,
Nicolas 32% et Marine 31%
donc c'est Marine qui est éliminée au premier tour
et si on simule le deuxième tour,
cette fois on a Nicolas 63% et François 37%.
Vous voyez le paradoxe !?
Dans la première situation François est élu
mais s'il récupère plus d'électeurs, il peut se retrouver perdant.
C'est ce qu'on appelle parfois le paradoxe d'Arrow.
Que ce soit dans un scrutin classique
à deux tours ou dans le vote alternatif,
en progressant dans l'opinion, on peut se retrouver
à descendre dans le classement.
C'est quand même absurde.
Outre le fait que c'est totalement incohérent comme situation,
ça ouvre la porte à ce qu'on appelle du vote stratégique.
Ici les partisans d'un candidat, François, auraient intérêt
à ne pas voter pour lui au 1er tour
et à voter pour Marine pour lui faciliter le deuxième tour.
Le vote stratégique c'est quand
on ne vote pas selon ses convictions
mais qu'on exploite les failles du système pour aider son candidat.
Allez! Autre paradoxe du système classique.
Imaginons trois candidats, Ségolène, Nicolas et François.
Je continue de prendre des cas réels, alors notez
quand même que ce n'est pas le même François.
Imaginons que l'opinion les classe de la manière suivante:
40% des électeurs préfèrent Nicolas à François
et François à Ségolène;
pour faire simple vous pouvez les appeler les électeurs de droite.
40% préfèrent Ségolène à François et François à Nicolas;
les électeurs de gauche.
10 % préfèrent François à Nicolas et Nicolas à Ségolène;
on peut les appeler centre-droit.
Et 10 % préfèrent François à Ségolène
et Ségolène à Nicolas; les centre-gauche.
Allons-y simulons le premier tour.
On prend le premier choix de chaque électeur,
Nicolas et Ségolène font 40%, François ne fait que 20 %
et se retrouve éliminé
et le deuxième tour va se jouer entre Nicolas et Ségolène.
Pourtant, si on faisait un duel François / Nicolas
et bien François gagnerait 60 - 40.
Et si on faisait un duel François / Ségolène
et bien il gagnerait aussi.
Donc François serait capable de battre chacun
des finalistes mais il n'arrive pas à aller en finale.
Encore une fois, si on fait la comparaison avec le sport,
c'est un peu bizarre.
Alors, cet exemple n'est pas totalement fictif.
A l'élection présidentielle de 2007,
il y avait douze candidats et les sondages de l'époque
prédisaient que François Bayrou
aurait battu en duel n'importe lequel des onze autres candidats,
sauf qu'il n'a pas réussi à aller au deuxième tour.
Cette situation ne date pas d'hier, elle avait déjà été
remarquée en 1785 par le marquis de Condorcet,
un philosophe et mathématicien qui a été le premier
à s'intéresser au système de vote de manière scientifique
et sur la base de cette constatation Condorcet
avait proposé une méthode de vote qui porte son nom,
la méthode de Condorcet.
On organise des duels entre tous les candidats,
des duels électoraux s'entend
et on garde celui qui réussit à battre tous les autres.
Ça paraît super!
Sauf que Condorcet avait remarqué qu'il y a
des situations où ça ne marche pas.
Il existe des cas où aucun candidat
ne peut être en capacité de battre tous les autres
et ça crée des choses vraiment bizarres.
Allez, imaginez qu'on ait trois candidats,
alors on va changer un peu, on va les appeler A, B et C.
Supposez qu'un tiers de l'opinion préfère A à B, B à C,
un tiers préfère B à C et C à A
et le dernier tiers C à A et A à B.
Si on fait un duel A contre B, donc on enlève C et bien A gagne.
Si on fait un duel B contre C, c'est B qui gagne.
Mais dans un duel A contre C et bien c'est C qui gagne.
C'est-à-dire qu'aucun des trois candidats
ne peut gagner ses deux duels.
C'est quand même bizarre.
On appelle ça le paradoxe de Condorcet.
Ce qui est étonnant c'est que, imaginez que A ait été élu
par n'importe quelle méthode de scrutin.
Dès le soir de son élection, si on faisait un référendum,
il y aurait les deux tiers de la population qui serait d'accord
pour le remplacer immédiatement par C
puisque C bat A dans l'opinion.
Mais si on fait ça, les deux tiers de la population
serait tout de suite d'accord
pour destituer C au profit de B puisque B bat C dans l'opinion.
Sauf que si c'est B le président, les deux tiers
de la population seraient d'accord pour revenir à A.
Donc il faut trouver autre chose.
Un contemporain de Condorcet avec qui
il avait pas mal discuté, le marquis de Borda,
avait proposé une variante.
Comme dans le vote alternatif,
chacun classe tous les candidats
et ensuite pour les départager,
on leur file des points comme à l'Eurovision,
par exemple, 1 point au dernier, 2 points à l'avant-dernier,
3 points à l'avant-avant-dernier etc...
et N points au 1er s'il y a N candidats
et celui qui a le plus de points gagne.
Si on applique ce mode de scrutin à notre situation
avec François, Nicolas et Ségolène,
on se retrouverait avec 190 points pour Nicolas et Ségolène
et 220 points pour François qui serait donc élu.
Ce mode de scrutin est par exemple utilisé
dans certains prix sportifs
et aussi pour certaines élections à l'académie des sciences.
Alors il paraît parfait non ?
Et bien, non pas vraiment, déjà, il dépend de la manière
dont on choisit de distribuer les points
et puis comme dans le scrutin majoritaire classique,
les petits candidats peuvent avoir
une influence décisive sur le résultat final.
Donc non, il n'est pas vraiment idéal.
[Générique]
Bon, tout ça est un peu décourageant.
On a regardé plusieurs systèmes électoraux
et aucun ne semble parfaitement satisfaisant.
Mais bon, au moins on sait déjà préciser un peu ce qu'on cherche.
On voudrait un système de vote
qui satisfasse au moins deux conditions.
La première c'est que, quand on progresse dans l'opinion,
on ne peut que progresser à la fin
et on a vu qu'avec le scrutin majoritaire classique,
ce n'est pas le cas.
La deuxième c'est qu'on voudrait
que le résultat final ne soit pas dépendant
de l'ajout ou du retrait d'un candidat mineur
qui n'a aucune chance d'aller au bout,
comme aux 100 mètres.
Cette question a été étudiée scientifiquement par
un économiste américain qui s'appelle Kenneth Arrow
et Arrow a démontré un résultat qui porte le nom
de théorème d'impossibilité.
En gros ce théorème dit qu'il n'existe aucun système électoral
qui puisse satisfaire ces deux conditions.
Et bien voilà! GAME OVER !
Le système électoral parfait n'existe pas.
C'est quand même un peu déprimant, non ?
Le théorème d'impossibilité nous dit que quoi qu'on fasse,
on ne pourra jamais élire correctement les gens qui nous dirigent.
Sauf que le théorème d'Arrow ne porte
que sur les systèmes de vote
où on exprime nos préférences en classant les candidats.
Mais en fait on peut y échapper
en utilisant un système de vote où on ne classe pas
les candidats mais où on les juge individuellement
et un système électoral très simple qui permet
de faire ça, c'est le vote par approbation.
Dans ce système, on peut voter
pour autant de candidats qu'on veut,
on ne peut évidemment pas voter plusieurs fois pour le même
mais on peut choisir de donner sa voix
à tous les candidats qu'on approuve.
A l'issue de ce scrutin on a le pourcentage
d'approbation de chaque candidat,
c'est-à-dire la fraction de l'électorat qui a choisi de l'approuver
et ce mode de scrutin est totalement insensible
aux jeu des petites candidatures.
S'il y a plusieurs candidats qui vous plaisent,
vous votez pour tous ceux-là,
il n'y a pas besoin de faire du vote utile.
Un des gros avantages de ce système c'est qu'il serait
extrêmement simple à mettre en place
et à dépouiller avec le fonctionnement actuel.
Il suffit juste de dire qu'on a le droit de mettre
plusieurs bulletins dans l'enveloppe,
un seul tour de scrutin et basta.
Le problème de ce système c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de gradation dans l'approbation,
c'est-à-dire que vous ne pouvez pas nuancer
entre un candidat que vous appréciez vraiment
et un candidat que vous toléreriez faute de mieux.
Pour aller plus loin, il faudrait être capable
de juger les candidats sur une échelle.
Ça n'a rien de révolutionnaire comme proposition,
c'est ce qu'on fait quand on a besoin de classer
des élèves, des films, ou bien des gymnastes
alors pourquoi pas des hommes politiques ?
On pourrait tout simplement imaginer
leur mettre à tous une note entre 0 et 20.
Bon, un problème c'est qu'il faudrait trouver une échelle commune !
Parce que 15/20 ça ne veut pas forcément dire
la même chose pour vous et pour moi.
L'autre problème c'est qu'on pourrait aussi peser
sur le vote en exagérant ses notes.
Par exemple, votre candidat préféré vous lui mettez 20
et vous mettez 0 à tous les autres,
même si dans le fond ce n'est pas ce que vous pensez.
Bon, au final, élire le président ou la présidente
en mettant des notes entre 0 et 20 à tous les candidats,
ce n'est peut-être pas une super idée.
Pour éviter ces travers, deux chercheurs français,
Rida Laraki et Michel Balinski,
ont proposé une méthode de vote qui permet d'éviter
tous les problèmes dont on a parlé aujourd'hui.
On l'appelle la méthode du jugement majoritaire.
[Générique]
Cette méthode est extrêmement simple à mettre en oeuvre,
au lieu de mettre des notes aux candidats,
on leurs attribue une mention, un peu comme au bac,
sur une échelle qui en compte 7.
Excellent, très bien, bien, assez bien,
passable, insuffisant et, à rejeter.
Le bulletin de vote ressemble à ça.
Pour présider la France, ayant pris
tous les éléments en considération,
je juge en conscience que ces candidats seraient...
et pour chaque candidat vous cochez une mention.
Alors comment est-ce qu'on dépouille ça, ensuite ?
Et bien, pour chaque candidat vous obtenez
un pourcentage pour chacune des mentions.
On va prendre un exemple fictif.
Imaginons un candidat auquel 9% des gens
aurait attribué la mention excellent,
très bien 14%, bien 16%, assez bien 15%,
passable 18%, insuffisant 15%, à rejeter 13%.
On représente ça graphiquement, comme ça.
Alors comment on interprète ça ?
Vous voyez que 9% de l'électorat accorderait
la mention excellent à ce candidat,
mais 23%, c'est-à-dire 9+14,
lui accorderait au minimum très bien,
c'est-à-dire, soit très bien, soit excellent
et 39% accorderait au minimum bien
et de même 54% de l'électorat lui accorderait
au minimum assez bien.
La mention assez bien est ce qu'on appelle
la mention majoritaire de ce candidat.
C'est la mention que plus de la moitié de l'opinion,
ici 54%, serait prêt à lui attribuer.
Pour trouver rapidement la mention majoritaire
d'un candidat, c'est très simple,
vous représentez les pourcentages
de toutes ses mentions de cette manière
et vous tirez un trait à 50%,
la mention sur laquelle vous tombez est sa mention majoritaire.
Du coup pour départager tous les candidats, on regarde
pour chacun quelle est sa mention majoritaire,
celle qui est approuvée par au moins 50% de l'opinion
et celui avec la meilleure mention majoritaire gagne.
Et en cas d'égalité, on peut départager avec les pourcentages.
Voilà ce qu'on appelle la méthode du jugement majoritaire
et on pourrait très bien utiliser cette méthode de scrutin
pour élire le président ou la présidente de la république.
Alors, qu'est-ce qui fait que cette méthode est si bonne ?
Bon, déjà, chaque candidat est jugé individuellement
sur son mérite personnel,
indépendamment des autres
et donc on n'a pas le problème des petites candidatures
qui vont influencer l'issue du scrutin.
Ici, s'il y a plus de petites candidatures, ça ne va pas changer
la mention majoritaire qu'un candidat va recevoir.
Du coup, avec la méthode du jugement majoritaire,
il n'y a pas de notion de vote utile,
vous avez juste à exprimer sincèrement
votre opinion sur chacun des candidats.
L'autre avantage de ce système,
c'est qu'il échappe au paradoxe d'Arrow,
c'est-à-dire qu'un candidat qui progresse dans l'opinion
ne peut pas régresser dans le classement final.
En plus, avec ce système du jugement majoritaire
on n'a aucun intérêt à voter stratégique,
c'est-à-dire à exagérer son vote
pour essayer d'aider son candidat.
Si votre candidat a obtenu
une mention majoritaire assez bien
que vous ayez voté bien, très bien,
ou excellent, ça ne change rien,
vous n'avez pas à exagérer votre vote,
vous avez juste à voter sincèrement
selon vos convictions personnelles.
Autre avantage de ce système, si tous les candidats
obtiennent comme mention majoritaire,
soit insuffisant, soit à rejeter,
on peut décider d'organiser de nouvelles élections
en exigeant de nouveaux candidats
et en interdisant à ceux-là de se représenter.
Vous voyez qu'une nouvelle méthode de vote
comme celle du jugement majoritaire
permettrait de choisir ceux qui nous dirigent
de manière moins aléatoire et plus représentative
et peut-être de réconcilier le peuple
avec ses élites politiques.
Si vous aussi vous pensez qu'on peut choisir
un meilleur système de scrutin pour élire le président,
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo,
notamment pour faire connaître
la méthode du jugement majoritaire.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, j'ai créé un petit billet
de blog pour apporter quelques compléments
et vous pouvez aussi aller voir cette vidéo de la chaîne
"La statistique expliquée à mon chat"
qui montre de manière assez remarquable comment, avec les mêmes chiffres,
suivant le système de vote qu'on utilise,
on peut obtenir un résultat différent.
Bien sûr, comme toujours, si vous aimez la science,
vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne pour ne rien rater.
Vous pouvez suivre mes actualités sur Facebook,
sur Twitter et vous pouvez aussi me soutenir sur Tipee.
Merci à tous, à bientôt.
Traduit par "serial cut".